[Music]
we have about 30 minutes to knock down
okay guys listen
you skate Potter gone and sub is out of
order and we're not getting any more
video signals and structure of the
capabilities distillery unsound captain
the really good punch line cuz it's
setup us so II week we go for the robot
the Roebuck it's a mile down a mile that
way what are you talking about yeah
however even get that we walk we what
walk so we just go into pitch black we
walk without knowing where we're going
with insufficient oxygen that's the plan
that's the plan
everybody down with that Nora you care
that the suits can't be down there that
long you know that not everyone here's
an experienced diver dad we never know
I'm not trying to be can you just admit
we might die doing that yeah but can you
admit that we might live doing this
[Music]
listen carefully
you are now 5,000 miles from land and
you're descending seven miles to the
bottom of the ocean
see you all in a bucket here we go but
if we do this let's do this
[Music]
on a scale from one to ten whole bugs my
rig I drilled to the bottom of the ocean
and we don't know what came out
gotta get to the station we even get
that walk we're just gonna walk with
insufficient oxygen across the bottom of
the ocean you'll know what's out there
oh is death
[Music]